welcome to this video playing just kit
is he playing the Kings Indian defense
this would be kind of fitting but ok
just kit can also refer to something
else but we actually get the kingsland
in your hands yeah one idea is to play
that really g4 and stuff here we go to
form now let's not pre move here I never
know what they might come up with
yeah f5 I guess otherwise I really don't
see any count to play for black I don't
see anything okay the blacks cult play
is not really obvious okay this one will
be six or so yeah maybe just Queen d2
end going for long castling
yeah okay this is a typical lashing out
stuff that's not working really but can
be irritating in blitz what do we do d
texts 6b four 9594 this might really
work maybe but okay let's let's take
this bond and see what what kind of
compensation he hopes to get
damn simplest looks a four but then I'd
be three is coming so that's not the
solution here okay okay let's just go
back
and this a lot behind on the clock
that's always some some sort you're
reassuring if you have a little bit of a
time advantage yeah wide radius is a
porn up and this strategically winning
on the King side the problem is that i
don't have a clear place for my king and
this is quite often a practical
practical issue of course so f three
maybe and it's going a form yeah that's
probably some kind of compensation maybe
not enough but some kind of compensation
it is
maybe Queen a three night before or
something like that I prepare say for
okay i will take them I mean I don't
like to open up the okay it doesn't take
what the f porn I was expecting that
actually oh crap look see let's get its
do this and cover this pawn this night
in advance okay bye i if i take with the
night is got 93 jackets it's all tricks
tricks tricks in this opening but it's
dangerous really dangerous okay that's
not panic I can take a six ok let's do
with that and now be a karate gonna do
that
between that it's really the problem of
those lines there might be really nice
quite often but you always have a bad
King and then they were swindled
swindling swindle yeah but luckily at
all would be too and I'd be five maybe
at the tower it looks very shaky I Queen
will just take it for something and then
that doesn't didn't really help night
look see to night before I'm lacking
just one movie an IDF 221 ok is actually
got night before I look be to King 23
night before what rubbish total rubbish
time warning yeah the typical Kings
Indian stuff you have a winning position
like I have to move 14 and then they
still get counter play if you are
playing it badly yeah come on here you
get your point white resins I might be
fire that's still okay actually I didn't
see that are I to frustrate it because
it never should come that far you have
to be five legis basic saying okay I'm
lost ya how everything's cool yeah but I
didn't didn't do it ok I can actually
take here and wind because night b5 is
possible and not 95 you cannot take here
because this is win why exactly does it
win this age six and okay that's
definitely come dead so layover bishop
on h8 ridiculous so that was much more
stronger okay well here you are you this
is just really just a pawn and but I
screwed it up this is probably too slow
this is to slow the engine wants to do
this f 3 f 5 and takes rook chairs look
take special d5l okay if you go at five
here you give up more material what
about this ambition of c4 and then just
92 and castles long yeah well it is
basically winning in many ways at least
in a long time control but I allowed too
much counter play bye-bye now it is not
a not easy at all Bishop c4 still
winning her I didn't really take that
into account Bishop c4 92 that's a
quicker way to finish development I
didn't think of this this is really bad
I only had this idea that night h3 f.2d
one but that's too
slow by now it is really tricky and
after this I'm in trouble and this is
correct I can do this and now i have to
do night and to this and now instead of
i reside now but 9 p-5 is the move that
i can still play I didn't see it
Chattanooga takes Queen takes Queen
takes castles and engine gives equal
yeah black is probably getting this pawn
here there was too frustrated that I
already had this that he or that he had
gotten this far I mean I always find it
remarkable like move 12y totally winds
here what is this and why do they allow
this in the first place that's when he
weird but okay it's blitz chess as we as
we have experienced he got away with it
and yet assessor this is bad really I
was only thinking about this move and
this is indeed absolutely not clear
because I move I move the Queen now I
have no good square that's one problem
and then black goes back and this is not
great at all I mean he's got Bishop f5
and so on I did not think about 95 here
at all but it's but it's just strong I
mean this is this is what the engine is
giving us the best line and it's really
this is just unplayable with this
ridiculous bishop him yeah bad flame
thanks for watching